if you want to hear about the
undiscovered rooms of the nerve gas
house that we never see in the movie
then stick around to the end of this
video um two things you missed
I love how cheerfully he says greetings
gets me every time director James Wan
would step away from the saw franchise
after the first film and opened the door
for a new face to take the reins on the
series so saw two would be directed by
Darren Linn Bausman
Bausman would head up the next three
movies and established most of what we
think of when we think of saw today I
considered the sauce I got to be more
his products than any other director and
he would return to direct the ninth
installment spiral with the new director
came some new things you missed so grab
your magnifying glass and let's get into
them
the movie opens the same way that the
first did with allies we see a bear
light bulb come in and out of focus and
it suddenly shines very bright in the
first saw I said that the light
represented jigsaw trying to enlighten
his test subjects and make them see the
error of their ways that concept took
more of a center stage in saw to making
this an appropriate opening some of
John's trap designs throughout the Saw
series took ancient torture devices and
enhanced them with industrial advances
one example is the first trap of the
movie The Venus flytrap which drew
inspiration from the medieval
contraption of the Iron Maiden only this
was more like a cute little Iron Maiden
for your face when the victim watches
his tape the assistant seen on screen
has a bit of a limp is a slight hobble
to his step if you've seen the twist at
the end of saw 7 you now know why if
you're about to correct me and say it's
called saw 3d or saw the final chapter
save your breath I prefer to call it saw
7 soon after we meet Eric Matthews who's
going to pick up his son Daniel who'd
been caught shoplifting at an
electronics store during the scene the
camera cuts away to a shot of a security
camera
which shows us the reason that Daniel is
so familiar with security technology
later on as types of cameras don't have
sound and more importantly established
one of the main concepts of jigsaws next
game part of what makes the twist work
is the fact that we as the audience
believe that what we're seeing on the
monitors is a live feed on a side note
this is one of the only movies to
establish a relationship that we care
about the father-son dynamic between
Eric and Daniel before they both get
tangled up with the jigsaw and it goes a
long way to help make this the most
powerful entry in the series on an
emotional level eric is called in to see
the jigsaw crime scene that we saw in
the opening because the killer has
called out detective Matthews a rather
detective Matthews as brilliant as
jigsaw may have been it looks like he
still struggles with spelling we know
that the double T's is the correct
spelling because that's how the names
appear in the end credits when Eric is
back at the police station many notices
and wanted posters cover the walls while
the shelves are filled with binders and
boxes of evidence files one of these
boxes is for a case about a victim named
Greg Copeland a reference to the
co-producer of Bosmans initial
three-song films who also served as a
production manager and a second unit
director another box in that room was a
victim named Charlie Taylor who is the
film's weapons Wrangler after Matthews
has the realization about the location
of jigsaws hideout the SWAT team makes
an entrance strategy on the whiteboard
which involved several small
teams of men the first team consisted of
black Faulkner and Whisman and braiding
which corresponded to electrician Craig
black key grip Chris Falconer or
possibly his brother Tyler first
assistant editor Ron wisdom jr. and the
art director and Michelle Brady okay
enough of that boring stuff you know
it's about to go down when jigsaw puts
away his cereal the main game of saw two
is the nerve gas house where eight
criminals must solve puzzles to win the
antidotes to the poison being pumped in
through the ventilation system from what
I've heard of the original scripts of
the film have detailed the specific
traps set for each character but the
final cut only shows the location of
five antidotes the one in the safe in
the room that they start off in the two
in the furnace trap the one in the
needle pits and the one in the razor box
of those five only one game was played
by the test subject it was intended for
which was Abby who was challenged to go
into the furnace trial according to the
director's commentary the razor box trap
was intended for Gus who doesn't make it
that far because he falls victim to the
Magnum I hole very early on normally I
wouldn't consider the information on the
commentary track canon so i wouldn't
include something like that in my things
you missed but we do see that Gus is a
businessman and the trap seems to have
been created to punish greed it's not
hard to imagine that Gus was chosen by
jigsaw because of corporate greed we
more or less find out why addison was
chosen and saw four and the razor box
trap doesn't seem to fit the bill for
prostitution so who were the other
antidotes supposed to go to in my head
cannon the second needle and Abhi's trap
would have gone to Daniel since he's
just a kid and you know all the usual
clichés about him having his whole life
ahead of him and stuff I'm not saying
that the other prisoners would have let
that happen but I think that's how
jigsaw drew up the game the only other
one that we know for a fact is the
needle pit trap which was intended for
Xavier but he ends up throwing Amanda
into the pit to do the task for him
speaking of which I think we can
subtract one because it seems pretty
clear that because Amanda was in on the
game she had already been treated this
is supported by the fact that she never
runs out of breath or spits up blood as
the others do so that leaves Laura
Addison and Jonas I think that the
antidote in the safe would have been for
Jonas because he seems most interested
in solving the riddle that jigsaw left
for them on the tape so it's likely that
John knew that he liked puzzles and that
would essentially become his task so
that just leaves Addison and Laura there
are plenty of locked rooms in the
corridors that we never see the inside
of and some of them seemed to just open
on their own and once a certain amount
of time has a lot
but neither of these characters lived
long enough to make it to their tasks
while we don't see the inside of their
rooms in the movie we can learn about
the traps that may have been inside them
if we take a closer look at the design
sketches pinned up all over jigsaws
workshop
John Kramer's headquarters at the Wilson
steel plant seem to be his go-to spot
for research and development taking a
look around the place is covered with
blueprints design sketches and
prototypes for traps which were tested
on the mannequin scattered around the
facility which were probably brought
over from his previous workshop at
stadium streets his location had been
compromised by detective Tapp in 2004
these designs include previous traps
like the original reverse bear trap
which we saw Amanda tested on in the
first movie or the Venus flytrap from
the opening of this movie many of the
sketches represent the traps at the
nerve gas house like the razor box in
the Magnum I hole if those are present
chances are we can also see the two
unseen traps from the nerve gas house
always intended for Laura and Addison
there are a number of traps that can be
seen in the workshop that don't
correspond to any trap that's used
during the series like this one which
appears to be some kind of skull cage
possibly with the intention of impelling
the victims head another variation on
the idea shows up later and looks to
introduce an electric shock component to
the design another design shows us some
kind of gas mask with a switch on the
front when we see more concept sketches
later one of them is labeled as the
toxin table though it is not known if
that is meant to be used in conjunction
with the gas masks this thing may or may
not be the toxin table assuming the gas
mask and the toxin table do you go
together though I guess this is the trap
for Addison I can see there being some
kind of analogy being made with toxins
being compared to disease and the gas
masks being compared to protection as it
pertains to the corner girl lifestyle we
don't ever find out why Laura is tested
by jigsaw but she would have the last
trap by default be it the electric skull
cage thing or one of these other
prototypes
another possibility is this football
helmet one but there isn't any evidence
of John getting started with any
preliminary designs on that there are
other trap designs that I think may be
very early versions of some of the other
devices John would use later in his
career
would you call serial killing a career I
mean I guess in his case it's more of a
retirement plan alone investment firms I
see that you frightened with Leamas
handled funds down
[Music]
but yeah right here I noticed a trap
that looks to be some kind of spinal
cord device which reminded me of the
spine cutter trap that art blank had the
wherein saw four there was also this
mannequin with a series of tubes running
from the head and I have to wonder if
that would be related to the oxygen
pressure that eventually appeared in saw
6 outside of what we actually see in
John's workshop there is also a moment
that I believe inspired future traps in
the series when John is talking to
detective Matthews he describes the
moment that his mission truly began when
he tried to take himself out Bill Murray
Groundhog Day style in the way he
describes what he felt is an important
stat in how he came to believe that his
traps would cause people to appreciate
what role it off the side of a cliff the
obvious trap idea to come out of this
would be the horsepower trap from saw 7
where one of the victims experiences a
car crash from the same perspective that
John would have when he threw his
vehicle into autopilot but there was no
autopilot because was the mid-90s but
after the crash John can be seen pulling
these stakes out of his body and I think
that's what gave him the idea for the
spike trap which he would use in sauce
for guys I am so good at reading Roman
numerals as this seems to be the part of
the experience that really made him feel
alive but enough about the traps let's
talk about the game the trap you shine
at the very beginning Amanda is asleep
face down on the floor like she's some
kind of taking back sunday lyric though
if anyone's a lyric in this movie it's
rigged Amanda who would be the
facilitator of the game at the nerve gas
house starts off in the exact same
position that John Kramer did when he
facilitated the bathroom game a year
prior Eric's son Daniel is wearing some
band merch for a group called wrath of
the gods those of you who saw my things
you missed episode on the first saw may
remember a character named Scott Tibbs
who was Adams childhood best friend who
also went on to make his own documentary
about jigsaw Scott's band in that
documentary is none other than wrath of
the gods
Scott Tibbs
the guitar found over at the guts last
week I said that the Scot tips
documentary was non-canon but after
watching it again there isn't really
anything that contradicts the movies so
I'm not sure why saw fans consider it to
be non-canon I think it's just because
they don't like it but outside of
Daniels wrath of the Gods shirt being a
reference to Scot Tibbs it also
represents the cult of jigsaw who would
come to see himself as a God so you
could say that he brought his wrath down
upon his many victims this wrath would
not extend to Daniel himself though and
jigsaw gives a couple of little clues
towards the boy being safe or at least
being in a safe place also later on when
he promises Eric that if he follows the
rules he'll see the Sun again he darts
his eyes down towards where the safe is
if you agree to that and you will see
your son again these clues given audibly
by jigsaw aren't the only hints that
what the police are saying on the
screens isn't taking place in real time
if we look at some more of the
background details of the workshop we
can find even more evidence
when police discover the numbers
counting down next to the monitors they
assume that it's a bomb and later decide
that it's probably a countdown to the
end of the nerve gas game however if you
do the math which normally I don't like
to do but we'll make an exception for
you the viewers the timer has over four
hours to go whereas the game was only
supposed to last two to three hours
there are also a few items seen in
built-in nerve gas house and the Wilson
steel plant items don't typically exist
in two places at once what I'm getting
at is the events taking place in the
computer screens cannot be taking place
at the same time as the police raid the
wheelchair with the mannequin upon which
the note for obvious found can be seen
in the room with the monitors the
tricycle that Billy the puppet used to
create the police when they first
arrived at the steel plant is also
present in the hallway over at the house
and the x marks the spot painting can be
seen hanging in the background in
jigsaws workshop earlier I mentioned
briefly how jigsaw developed a god
complex and this painting has a very
biblical look to it like something you
might find in a church he probably does
consider his workshops to be his
churches going so far as to light
candles to perform a ceremony on Amanda
in saw 3 the signal traced by the
Metropolitan Police's tech team leads
them back to a different house where
Rigg hits pause in the VCR to determine
that the game that they had been
watching on the screens all along was
already over one question you might have
had is where jigsaw is getting all of
these empty houses and buildings fans of
the franchise know that John Kramer was
once involved in a project called the
urban renewal group which helps provide
housing to low-income families but he
abandoned the endeavor halfway through I
think if the nerve gas house was going
to be one of these homes but John
reinforced it to make it the setting of
his game the fake-out house was probably
a replica or model home which would
explain why it has the same layout and
why jigsaw was able to trick the SWAT
team the twist in this movie works great
because as the audience were on the same
level as the protagonist the police we
are being presented the events out of
order because that's how they are
perceiving the situation we find out the
truth as they find out whereas in a
movie like jigsaw the story is told the
way that it is just to trick the
audience there's no other practical
reason for doing it that way and it
feels artificial another thing that saw
two gets right that you may not have
thought about is the theming of the
traps to fit the character who is
playing them for example it seems the
needle pit room was once a nursery you
see a
he's written on the walls baby bottles
toys carriages and even creepy little
infant mannequins Xavier has revealed to
have been a drug dealer who took
advantage of his clients addictions when
a junkie becomes addicted their body
becomes dependent on the drugs just as a
baby in a nursery needs its parents to
provide for its the drug addicts need to
keep crawling back to Xavier to get
their fix
desperation seems to be a key theme in
the film had Abby not been so desperate
to get both antidotes he could have seen
the nozzle to turn off the flames of the
furnace trap with minimal burn damage
had Addison not been in such a huge rush
to obtain the antidote in the Razr box
she might have noticed that it was
already unlocked which would allow her
to open it up and get what she needs
without putting her wrists in harm's way
and had everyone just taken a moment to
sit down and think about the clues given
by jigsaw they could have figured out
that each of them had numbers written on
the back of their heads each one with a
different color of the rainbow by
arranging them in the order of ROYGBIV
red orange yellow green blue indigo and
violet it would have obtained the
combination to the safe
the big one of course is Eric Matthews
whose desperation to find his son led
him back to the ways of police brutality
all he had to do to get his son back was
sit there and talk with a jigsaw when
the contestant of the game discovered
the X they find the photo proving that
Daniel Matthews is Eric Matthews son in
the photo they write in New York Knicks
game while the location of the Saw
movies is in an unnamed fictional City
that's only ever nicknamed the
Fairweather States there are a lot of
clues like this that it's supposed to be
somewhere in the northeastern United
States like the license plates being
very similar to New Jersey and the New
York skyline in the spiral trailer about
73 minutes into saw - there's this three
minute stretch where there's just a
whole bunch of horror references for
some reason it starts when the tech team
discovers the location of the fake-out
house which is 237 North Hyde Crescent
237 is no match to the spookiest number
and Olive horror
room 237 from The Shining if you aren't
a big fan of The Shining you might think
this is just a coincidence but trust me
when I say it's not you pay attention
you'll notice this number come up over
and over again in all kinds of horror
films the way that Hyatt is spelled
makes me think it could be a nod to the
classic novel dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
then there's another potential street
name homage
it's a bit unusual to see a first name
used as a street name like that and the
murder-mystery house nature of saw 2
leads me to believe that this was a
reference to perhaps the most iconic
horror director of all time Alfred
Hitchcock another iconic horror director
was Wes Craven and his 1972 film Last
House on the Left would also be
mentioned on the car ride after this we
see the conclusion of the nerve gas
house game as I mentioned in the last
episode one of the staples of the Saw
franchise is that there's always a
character who plays dead in order to get
an upper hand in this case it's Daniel
who plays dead to get the jump on Xavier
I can't show that because it's too gory
for YouTube but look someone finally
flushed the toilet and that's one of the
last things that I'd like to compliment
saw 2 on it decided which aspects of the
first movie would become staples of the
series and set the tone that would be
used for the next 5 installments it goes
back to what I was saying earlier about
this really being Darren Linn Bauman's
franchise he departed after sophomore
but handed the torch to the production
designer that he brought on for his Saw
movies David Hackl and David would hand
it off to the series editor and Kevin
Rooter to finish it out so the team was
all together as early as saw - part of
the reason that the tone is consistent
saw - would establish Bausman as a
director but the biggest box-office
success in the franchise would be his
next endeavor saw 3 so make sure you
join me on the next episode of things
you missed by subscribing this Easy's
world for new Horrors every week
bringing that death bell for
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
you